[Music]
the last three years on Franklin and
bash you've been working with one of the
great he's just terrific actor mr.
Malcolm McDowell yes and and why we you
know he's a terrific yeah yeah I would
find him I've met him a bunch of times
I've interviewed him and I think just
because of all the amazing roles that
he's played is he an intimidating guy
yeah he's Malcolm super intimidating and
he's also he's scary he's funny he's
scary again and he's like he's like a
little minx like he's just always always
kind of he and I go toe to toe for some
reason we just got off on a great foot
of like pranking each other and goofing
and he always calls me you know the
[ __ ] to the small one and things like
that oh my god just still hope you die
soon you know we ain't come back that's
quick well I hope you die pretty quick
but uh we were we were at the we were on
our way back from the Turner thing in
New York right and it was kind of fancy
they had their own plane um which is
cool and so we're going through security
and Malcolm right in front of me just
says you know he's got his bag there and
it's a cooler bag than mine he's got a
very nice bag here and he's all you know
cool white hair looks like kind of a
shaved Gandalf and he's like and he puts
his bag on his - the security guys good
by the way check the little one for
cocaine and get something real check the
little one for cocaine yeah I know yeah
he said that to the Tees TSA people's
TSA TSA people and I kind of walk out to
my hat I was in clueless he's kidding
you know it's
they literally were like yeah I remember
you includes could you stand right over
there please and take your bag I think
you can't joke about that
no well Malcolm can cuz he's on the
plane now just laughing and having tea
or whatever he does I don't know if you
guys have ever been pulled over for
cocaine possession I haven't but all you
start thinking is what's in my bag that
could resemble like I have a little
daughter you know I don't know yeah
paranoid why baby powder did I eat a
powdered donut do I would is there
anything in the bag and nothing says
like I have cocaine more than thinking
you don't and knowing you don't but
being terrified right so Mike you can
look in it you can look at whatever you
want guys you can look at look at never
was bag I let me carry with you you can
look at whatever bag you why yeah I
should say I didn't have any okay okay
cuz it was Thursday yes it would be a
definitely a different story if I had a
ton of you know I'd be doing this
interview on a phone yeah so my goal is
to somehow hide a balloon of heroin on
Malcolm McDowell at some point well yes
no you can't do that that's I said it
that's a terrible crime Malcolm if
you're watching I'm coming no it'll be
Malcolm full of grace I will just slowly
somehow he sleeps at the mouth open so
just massages throw worse prank I've
ever heard of
what did you just do I just put a
balloon of heroin in his mouth or is it
the greatest prey or what do you do like
this
somebody better x-ray clockwork go on do
it
yeah hey somebody check Gandalf is in
candy well uh I'm like this when I talk
to TCP people is that's how you doing
cool boy that's his gesture yeah well he
did it to you so to me so you know
whatever's good for the goose is good
for good what's up Twitter yeah I'm the
nerd suddenly I see Josie right now
Monaco show red got me now wait a minute
that went from a nerd to an old
prospector you do you and Mark Paul get
together and he's like going in and
you're like yeah it's mark ball cuz
you're taller than me we should yeah we
do now you may get something more pugazh
when i ride around on a bicycle built
for two
going lalalalala if the bike fits you
know I'm a little jealous I don't know
if you're getting that I'm a little
jealous of your friendship you can come
with us no work and we'll get you a
smaller bike no no forget Andy Andy and
I'll go do something yeah yeah what do
you guys know we yeah
like I don't know a car yeah two cars
I'll follow yeah we'll wave each other
suck it Oh Brian awesome this is amazing
handy-dandy it's gonna be the best well
you win again
yeah Joyce have the ultimate capper I
hope you die